Hó chú tìm của đồng anh nền, chuy mày chuy mà phải đáp mới đưa giả đánh giá,
bây tình hình kìm sốt vô kiện nhận và chiến vọng xa hàng hiếp bước các giảm vô ki tấn công chữ lực mới liêu stọng,
giống ngày và Mỹ, ông cho biết là mắt các vah hiểm chuy nhìn được phản hồi chính đất từ Washington.
Đối với đây, sớm xa hàng hiếp thêm 1 năm, trong khi thời hạng đưa giả quý định quay cùng của phía Mỹ,
là ngày 1 năm tháng 2, ông mới phải đáp nhận định niêu stọt từ góp phần duy triệu định chữ lực
và hạng chiến quyết cơ trẻ đưa vô kiện nhận, sâm trời rằng còn tụng tại khá biệt trong các tiếp tận dưới hành lình.
Chúnga cần cuối tính ngày càng phức tạm, phó chú tìm thị khuy đồng anh nền ngà dự báo,
số cuo ra sự hú vô kiện nhận có thể ra tăng khi một số nước coi đây là lựa trọn bảo đảm anh nền.
Ông trời rằng có là bộ hạp nhên sẽ tìm được được mơ giọc.
Cũng theo ông, Mét Vy Đép, hạm nhìn đống với trò thêm chốt với anh nền cuo ra,
vàng ai có thể đã không còn tụng tại nếu không sử vô kiện nhận.